I hadn't really even thought about film
at all as a prospect a career prospect I
I moved to Cardiff when I was 16 and
started having singing lessons and
that's where I thought oh maybe I could
have a career in musical theater but it
wasn't until I actually won a
scholarship and went to college that I
realized I could actually do that for a
living and it was very happy once I
graduated and was doing theatre and I
think there were points in the first 10
years of my musical theater career where
I wanted to be seen for maybe a TV
series or or soap or commercial but
never film film was like in a different
place it was not that wasn't me so the
fact that it did happen is is is is a
still very bizarre to me that actually
happened at 30 years old you know I've
tried had a 10 year career
I didn't know anything about film acting
I hadn't really done you know I'm not a
I didn't go to rodder didn't go to a
drama college I went to a musical
theater College so I'd learned my acting
from you know through music and you know
all the other stuff so I had to
basically just watch and and and and
learn very very quickly the first thing
I realized was that nobody talks loud
nobody's projecting anything you know
and in fact most of the time some of the
scenes I did with Liam Neeson and ray
Fiennes I couldn't even hear most of all
they said which was really bizarre and
then realizing they were miked up you
know and that they could speak very
naturally and you know
I learned that one very quickly so that
reduced my you know my performance level
to a very different place but it was it
was terrifying I mean I'm not gonna lie
it was I I was absolutely breaking it
you know that first day I was on set
with Liam Neeson and you know in Mount
Olympus dressed in you know 24 karat
gold-plated armor made for me with long
hair I mean crazy yeah and that was my
first experience have been on a film set
I mean I think I'm in the film flight 12
minutes altogether but it was an
important moment because it was a was a
big movie it was with Warner Brothers
and just to start a film career with
something like that on your CV really
helped open more doors you know but one
of the first things I ever learned for a
character was in Tamara Drewe which is
the factory the first year I did so I
started the year with Clash of the
Titans and I finished it with Tamara
Drewe and the character was a sort of
handyman farmer sort of kind of person
and he had to build a hazel fence
hazel fence doesn't have any nails you
know it's just chamfered edge pieces of
hazel wedged in two upright posts so I
went down to Dorset about a month before
we started shooting and worked with
hazel fence makers the scene to work it
up because actually the scene in the
film which thankfully is in the film
after all that preparation is happening
while I'm building a hazel fence so I
just wanted to become second nature so
that was sort of like the first time I
tried something that benefitted
massively when I actually did it on
camera and then these other things you
know that you have to dig very deep if
it's a character that you know has gone
through something very traumatic maybe
or is doing something the u n-- s not
necessarily would do yourself or that
the character thinks very differently to
you you have to somehow find the
humanity in what they're doing
the the the reality of what they're
doing is is the most important thing
because as long as you believe it then
you know the audience will believe it
you know whether you are killing a
dragon or you know chewing somebody's
neck
the average feature of a Studios size
film takes about three months maybe
maybe a little yeah maybe a little more
maybe a little less so we were in
Budapest for seven months so that was
the biggest sort of difference is
staying within a character and his
journey for basically what was ten hours
which is you know five five movies you
know back-to-back so that was an
interesting thing but it was actually a
very nice thing and I enjoyed it because
it you get to develop your character and
you when you start living with a
character for so long you you just start
you know thinking like them and you you
become sort of their their guardian in a
way so that when the new director and
the new scripts come in you have to have
to talk about it because I don't think
John would say that you know actually no
John wouldn't say that and I know John
wouldn't be seen there or I know he
wouldn't be drinking this so I know he
wouldn't you know interact with that
person in that way I think he would do
this and it was quite nice because
there's a respect from the directors and
the you know the creative team because
you know Daniel Dakota and myself put a
lot of work into preparing for those
characters and you know they're very
complex people and they're all very
they'll have their dark sides and
carrying their baggage and my character
more than all of the rest this with his
vices and addictions and all that stuff
so there was a there was a lot to think
about which I loved I loved every minute
of it and it is nice to do something for
a long period because you you get to
develop the character and also you know
two hours is not really sounds like a
long time it's actually not that long so
10 hours to live in a character's
journey was very nice very enjoyable
there's a lot of exciting things
bubbling away and you know there's a lot
of very interesting stories interesting
people but I can't talk I can't talk to
you about them because they're all in
development right now
one I'm producing which I absolutely
can't talk about another one which I'm
in talks about playing it's a true story
and another true story as well once
crime one's just a brilliant story and
the other one is something I've always
dreamed of playing that character and to
be able to you know produce it as well
and be part of the whole development
which is what I've been doing with them
with a Welsh writer in Los Angeles which
we've been sort of working with us on
the script for nearly 12 months now and
it probably has another 12 months to go
it's taken almost 10 years for me to
actually get around to actually being
considered or these ideas came up that I
thought about but yeah they're happening
and I feel like there's probably have a
very Welsh few years coming up which is
which is great you know I'm very proud
of Wales and my home and the people that
I've looked up to as a child who've done
very well for themselves and whatever
career industry they are in so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]